We've added the so called Superman Deterrent.
What we are seeing is a crime wave around the world.
What did you this weekend Diana?
Me?
Mm.
Nothing very interesting.
No protectors here.
No Lanterns.
No Kryptonian.
This world will fall.
Like all the others.
Gone is the days when one's biggest concerns
were exploding wind-up penguins.
This is crazy.
Fighting the devil and his army... in hell.
Don't engage alone.
We do this together.
Its really cool you guys seem ready to do battle and stuff
but I've never done battle
I just push some people and run away.
Relax Alfred, I'll take it from here.
Er, do i know you?
Superman is a beacon to the world.
He didn't just save people.
He made them see the best parts of themselves.
I don't recognize this world.
You don't have to recognize it.
woooohoooooo!!!
You just have to save it.
How many of you are there?
Not enough.
Do you really think that.. ?
Oh wow they just, they really just vanished...
huh, oh..
thats rude.
He said you'd come.
Now lets..
hope...
you're not too late.